[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in nick wright first things
first co-host are you a baseball fan
not so much but i'm a fan of hearing you
rail about how back in my day you valued
some ducks on the pond
it wasn't all about the long ball
back when men were men and the game was
played the right way i could have
listened to that for a while
but that doesn't mean i'm wrong in what
i said
no you're right uh i mean no you're
listen
here's a take
uh baseball's gotten too smart for its
own good
and every once in a while you're talking
about analytics
yeah i i am because that's to me when
you say you don't know how much they
value base runners
like every once in a while sports
leagues need to have a moment of
humility
and recognize there is nothing
inherently more valuable
from the world's best baseball or
basketball player compared to the
world's best highlight and frisbee
golfer the reason they make the muck the
difference in money is because people
enjoy watching them and every once in a
while the pursuit of winning
uh undercuts the watchability i think
that's happened with baseball and i
think you have to take it very very
seriously because i see it starting to
happen with basketball with uh
you know kind of the how it's all
three-pointer you know centric about who
wins and loses is what made basketball
as popular as it was was guys are flying
through the air super human feats and
because the smart numbers in baseball
and basketball have driven you away from
some of the most exciting parts of the
game that's a risky game to be played in
the entertainment business and if you
need to tweak rules accordingly you
should well basketball used to be about
movement and there's less movement in
basketball now it is
everybody is on the perimeter and
waiting for their turn to take take a
shot you still have unbelievable players
and then in college
college there was some bad basketball
played in march madness you know because
of the proliferation of the three-point
shot everybody thinks they can shoot it
and even though it's closer
uh there's a lot of guys who should not
be taking threes
well listen college basketball
in part because of the racial dynamics
of it and also in part because of just
people's own kind of nostalgia to it
people have convinced themselves people
they oh my god it's great defense in
college basketball no it's not it's
terrible offense it's guys that can't
shoot it's guys with open jumpers and
missing it
and i mean i feel like dan you could you
you could to this day provide eight
minutes off the bench just with some
quality jump shooting in college
basketball so yeah you know there's a
lot of a lot of the kind i joke with you
about the back in my day stuff but a lot
of it's true like there are certain
things that need to be refined a bit
more similarly to how they once were
done that part's fair
i wanted to have you on about the lakers
situation of what they do moving forward
here
a lot of people came out and said you
know they were unfair to frank vogel
i don't know what role he played in this
if you want to start there and then we
could look at what kind of coach can
they get should they get for next year
well let's start with vogel let's just
say
dan out of seemingly nowhere this show
had its worst year
in the history of the show it was a
failure on all accounts at all levels
do you think paulie gets fired maybe you
think paulie gets fired if maybe he's
only been there for three years probably
is it all paulie's fault no but when you
have the worst in a 70-year history a
lot of people should be fired the only
real issue i have with vogel getting
fired is it looks like polinka is going
to escape any accountability and i i i
think palink is far more accountable
than vogel is but
the lakers blew the second most
double-digit leads of any team in
basketball this year that's got to be a
little bit of coaching right the fact
that
at this very moment the player with the
eighth most starts for the lakers this
year was deandre jordan deandre jordan
like that's an active coaching choice
and it was the wrong one and maybe no
one could have reached russ but it is
the coach's job to try to so i don't
feel badly for frank vogel i also don't
think firing frank vogel solves it but i
also think dan when we see coach of the
year ballots taylor jenkins is going to
win but you know who also is going to
get a lot of votes ty lue monty williams
jason kidd what do those three names
have in common they all want to coach
the lakers and so that also doesn't help
frank vogel i don't think
you know russell westbrook said look we
never connected him and vogel
and and it is incumbent upon the coach
even though you might not want that
player you still need that player to
help you and i wonder if vogel used
russell westbrook the the correct way or
to to maximize russell westbrook
dan i listen russell one of my favorite
players ever to watch i use say all the
time how i found it borderline inspiring
how hard he went every game i think
that's a huge part of sports and i
thought he was a guy if you have kids
growing up playing it's like hey watch
this guy you can't tell what quarter it
is what game it is he's given is all out
but
russell westbrook to me is in denial and
his press conference yesterday showed it
and i don't think there is a proper way
to use it so i'm going to use a quick
story and an analogy and follow me on it
you've heard the old anecdote about your
parent finds their kids smoking so like
you're going to smoke this pack of
cigarettes and you're never going to
want to smoke again and
sometimes that works and sometimes the
kid gets addicted right so i had
something similar happen to me when i
was young
playing my dad in pool i maybe have told
the story i'm not sure playing him in
nine ball couple dollars on the five
five dollars on the nine and i am
crushing him like my dad stinks at pool
so he's like oh you got to let me change
to get my money back like okay raise the
stakes whatever you're awful at this he
won a hundred and eleven dollars for me
dan
i was 12 years old he made me pay it
back over the course of 18 months and he
thought here's the reason i'm telling
this story he thought the lesson i was
learning was don't gamble
the lesson i took from it was is my god
if you're good at gambling you can make
a lot of money and such is my life
so
so
here's why i tell that story
i think the 2017 season for russell
westbrook was that pack of cigarettes
moment that pool game and he took the
wrong lesson 2017 scoring title mvp
triple double in the playoffs had a
50-point triple-double that they lost
games two three four five of the
playoffs they lost three of four he
averaged 41 12 and 12.
that was a fork in the road moment first
year without durant where he could have
learned wow
i led the league in scoring average of
triple double i averaged 40 a game in
the postseason and we stunk
i need to adjust the lesson he took from
it was this is fun and awesome and i
guess my teammates got to figure out how
to pick up the slack and he's now has a
half decade of these great numbers prior
to this year no success and won't learn
from it so i you know my buddy broussard
who i host the show with dan he's been
bringing up iverson
and if you iverson in 2008 dan was 26
points a game all-star led the league in
minutes played all 82 games that was
2008. iverson in 2010 was in turkey
it can go quick man
and i worry about that for russ
and i can't change him at 34.
no
you know he's he's not somebody who can
adapt like kevin love did with the
cavaliers chris bosh did with the miami
heat
his his like mellow did yeah how about
mellow with the blazers yeah after
laughing about coming off the bench was
valuable for them and he didn't even
really have to adapt his game selling
mello's like i'm gonna be a lockdown
defender mello's game was the same but
he accepted a different role i don't
think russ is willing to do that it's
really worrying for him
and andre iguodala he was not at the
level at russ but he he understood his
role and really embraced that i mean he
went
from being a scorer to a defensive
minded player defensive stopper there i
just think with all that athleticism i
should get more out of russ
it's just i think because he has all
that athleticism i get less because he
still tries to do more i would never let
him take a jumper i would say take it to
the hoop and play great defense use that
athleticism go to the boards do the
smaller things
not taking 15 18-foot jumpers
and listen i thought and i think that's
what lebron thought i think lebron
thought i'll be able to get my arms
around him and we'll get the good of
russ which is the fearlessness the
availability which he should get credit
for the one laker that was available all
year uh and not get the bad part but it
was almost nothing but the bad part this
year could you see quinn snyder or doc
rivers entertain the idea of coaching
the lakers
so
here's the thing on that
it the only way it happens and i think
wilds who i know is your favorite member
of the television show um i i think
wilds made this point the only way that
happens is if those guys fail this year
right like the only way that doc rivers
is available is if the sixers get
knocked out early round one or round two
and the only way quincy is available is
if the same thing happens to the jazz so
do you want like if those guys got fired
would they entertain the possibility
yeah i think they would but would that
make sense for the lakers i'm not
certain i like the idea of juwan howard
personally i like what he's done at
michigan i don't mind occasionally
putting your hands on somebody i think
sometimes you know you need that uh so
yeah i like i like the idea of juwan
ben simmons making his debut maybe in
the playoffs insane like you don't think
this is gonna happen right
i hope it doesn't happen
like he's been through a lot and now i'm
going to just throw him in there and
you know have him introduce himself to
his teammates on a fast break i just it
just feels like
they could use him but it feels like
it's a little it's uh i have trepidation
it's pie in the sky it's nonsense he hey
the people are talking about him
returning to the nets he he's never
gotten
he's arriving with the next he's never
played a game with them like the
first andy hasn't played a game
since the playoffs last year which was
his lowest professional moment i think
it's nuts i think that anything
involving ben simmons has to be next
year now of course they need him can i
tell you a net scenario dan and this
would be a great time a great
opportunity for you to pay back that you
know night out on the town you owe me if
the nets lose tonight
and the hawks win tomorrow
we get a chance for trae young who is so
deep in new york sports fans head that
they're chanting f trey young at yankee
games
gets a chance to after eliminating the
knicks last year eliminate the nets in
barclays on thursday night so i think
the nets will win tonight but god hawks
nets which by the way this is where you
come in you know
anywhere in the first five rows is fine
i can meet you there uh seeing that in
person would be epic theater i know the
league wants the nets in the playoffs
but trey young sending both knicks or
both new york teams home within 12
months of each other would be
unbelievable
i'm i'm more courtsider bust when it
comes to yeah yeah well then buy it
what do you mean they're available guess
what it marks
good seats
i
hey great to talk to you as always have
fun tonight at the game
a little quick hook after i try to get
you back
i'm up against a break do you understand
how radio works
oh yeah sure can you hear the music wait
do you hear the music
that means to update that
same music for 30 years buddy
thanks nick
see ya that's nick
[Laughter]